the jurogan experience
he was one of uh nick's training
partners he's been a training partner of
nick's forever like nick diaz that guy
joe schilling oh my god i thought you
meant the guy that got knocked out
wait what the [ __ ] joe schilling yeah he
was there at the diaz fight and um
you know my thing about nick diaz is
like when i looked at him physically i
was like i don't know how much he's been
training like when
nick was in his prime
he was like really lean and he was you
know i mean he's definitely he's like an
older guy now and how old though i think
he's like 30 i don't know how old is 38
38 is he really yeah
but the thing is like i don't think you
can just jump back in that easy after
six years out of the sport i think you'd
probably need more time to prepare i
don't know he kind of got [ __ ] right
well i don't know how much time he had
to prepare and why they agreed to do a
fight on short notice i think it was
only like six weeks notice which i think
was is fine if you are you know michael
chandler if you're in like peak form
right now and you're ready to go and
someone gives you six weeks i bet you
can get ready for a fight but if you're
a guy who's been off for that long
you're gonna need more time i think i'm
just guessing i don't i don't know how
much time it took him but
my point was he didn't do that bad for a
guy that was out six months yeah you
know robbie lawler was pressuring him
and he was putting it on him and he was
definitely getting the better the
exchanges but it's not like nick diaz
didn't have his moments and he
definitely did
he would just have to have
really like way more time to prepare he
and he would have to really be like
ready to go
like the old nick diaz like the nick
diaz at fought anderson silva like the
nick diaz at fort george st pierre like
the nick diaz that fought paul daly in
strikeforce i mean that dude was a
[ __ ] killer it's just like can he
still do that at 38 well
maybe we don't know if you just have one
fight you need time like
if your body hasn't been used to this
stuff and you haven't been training as
much as you were when you're in your
prime if you still want to do it again
like legitimately physically you
probably can but it's like you know
you've run a marathon
when you start out and you run a mile
and you're dead and you're like i can't
believe anybody could run 26 of those
but if you do it over and over and over
again you build up i don't think he had
a chance i don't think nick diaz had a
chance to build back up after being off
for that much time i think you get back
to where he was nick diaz in his best
you got to like he's got to have some
time those diaz brothers were great for
their [ __ ] their pace they could last
the whole [ __ ] fight because they're
cardio well it's they're they're always
in the triathlons and [ __ ] they got
crowned gracie into that too
well yeah it's one of the reasons why
he's so good this is trying to most
terrifying thing i've ever done in my
life oh my god man i'm running the new
york city marathon when's that
november 6th how are you doing that like
this i don't know joe what the [ __ ] you
doing you watching i don't know you saw
you know what it is
up into the cage i'll figure i'll figure
it out robbie thoroughly won't be there
why would you just uh
make yourself smaller first i don't know
we should do another cocktail
i'm gonna try to lose weight i'm gonna
try to lose weight watch the entire
episode for free only on spotify